ضربه اوكرانيه دقيقه وموجعه ودميه قتل
وجرحى من الجنود الروسي
موسكو اقرت بمقتل 63 جنديا لكن كيف تقول
ان العدد اكبر من ذلك بكثير
الهجوم وقع في شرق اوكرانيا تحديدا بمدينه
مكيفكه شرقي دونيتسك التي تسيطر عليها
روسيا
اربعه صواريخ مارس ضربت مركزا انتشار مؤقت
للجيش الروسي في المدينه العمليه العسكريه
نفذت بناء على معلومات استخباراتيه دقيقه
تقول مصادر مواليه في دونيتسك ان استخدام
المجندين الروس الواصلين الى المعسكر
لهاتفهم المحموله وبكافه سمح للجيش
الاوكراني بتحديد موقعهم الجغرافي خطا
روسي فادح وقاتل سبق ان تكرر في حرب
اوكرانيا فالقوات تعتمد بشكل متكرر على
اجهزه اتصالات وخطوط غير امنه او مؤمنه
كالهواتف المحموله واجهزه الراديو التي
تعمل بنظام الضغط للتحدث الهجوم الاخير
يعكس قدرا كبيرا من التقدم الاوكراني في
الحرب الالكترونيه بفضل مكيف بمعدات غربيه
متطوره
بحسب خبراء فان اوكرانيا يستفادت من
الاتصالات الروسيه نفسها
وحجزت اشارتها واعمت رقابتها واستولت على
بعض انظمه الحرب الالكترونيه الاكثر تقدما
لكن ثم من يرى ان القاده الروس العسكريين
اخطاوا حين افترضوا ان الجيش الاوكراني لم
يتطور كثيرا منذ عام 2015
كما اخطاوا حين تجاهلوا تاثير المعدات
الغربيه وتدريب النيكل الوحدات الاخرانيه
غير ان القيود الروسيه وهميها العسكريه
جديده المركزيه اسهمت في ابطال قواتها
باتخاذ قرارات ميدانيه سريعه ومستقله امر
حولها الى اهداف سهله امام وحدات
الاوكرانيه اكثر استقلاليه وان كانت اقل
عددا وعتادا